Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the
Kurdish language,
whereas Curtis Spoken,
well,
that's an interesting question.
Kurdish is the language of the Kurdish
people and ethnic group who did not have
their own independent country.
They mostly live in the Kurdistan
region,
which consists of much of southeast
Turkey,
northeastern Syria and northern Iraq in
northwestern Iran,
as well as some other isolated areas and
the former Soviet Union Kurdish as the
majority language spoken in those areas,
there are approximately 30 million
native speakers of Kurdish.
That includes around 14.5
million in Turkey,
5.6
million in Iraq,
6 million in Iran and around 2 million
in Syria.
It also includes a Kurdish diaspora
living outside of the Kurdistan region,
most notably in Germany,
like Persian.
Kurdish is a member of the indoor
running and branch of the Indo European
language family,
but we're as Persian belongs to the
southwestern sub branch.
Kurdish belongs to the northwestern
sub-branch.
Persian and Kurdish share many
similarities,
but they're not mutually intelligible.
The history of the Kurdish language is
the subject of much speculation for much
of its history.
The Kurdish language was not a written
language.
Folk Tales and poetry were passed down
orally from generation to generations
with few exceptions.
The earliest written Kurdish texts come
from the 15th century and later there
was one known poem from the seventh
century written in the garden.
He dialect,
but technically the granny dialect is
actually a separate language from
Kurdish.
Okay.
Wait,
this is getting confusing.
Let me back up for a minute.
What is the Kurdish language?
Is that one unified language that all
Kurdish people can understand and speak?
No,
not really.
It's a collection of related dialects
spread out across a continuum,
meaning that the language changes
gradually over a geographic distance.
There are three main dialect groups of
Kurdish.
Could Umangi Sorta Tony and pat.
Hello honey.
The most widely spoken is could Umangi
with around 20 million native speakers.
It is the major dialects spoken in
Turkey as well as in Syria and some
parts of Iraq and parts of Iran.
The second most widely spoken is sorta
knee with six or 7 million native
speakers,
mainly in Iraq and Iran.
The third most widely spoken is hello
ani,
which is spoken by about 3 million
people in some Kurdish areas in Iran and
one district in Iraqi Kurdistan.
These three dialects have a relatively
low degree of mutual intelligibility,
so some people consider them to be
distinct languages and not just dialects
of one language.
The differences between these dialects
have been compounded by the fact that
the Kurds are spread out across several
different countries and have no central
media or a school system and haven't had
much interaction with the other areas of
Kurdistan and there has also been some
influence from the official languages of
the countries where they live.
Could Umangi is written in a Latin
alphabet like Turkish,
while [inaudible] is written in a pair,
so Arabic script Atla one is written in
either script on top of these main
critic dialects or critic languages
depending on how you look at it.
There were also some other languages by
some Kurds,
a few million Kurds speaky.
There's as that or go annie,
which form a separate sub branch of the
northwestern Iranian languages.
They're still quite closely related to
the Kurdish dialect and since they are
spoken by Kurds,
some people consider them to be Kurdish
dialects for reasons related to cultural
and ethnic identity.
Okay.
A big part of the story of Kurdish is
the desire for linguistic freedom.
In Turkey.
The Kurdish language was heavily
suppressed.
For decades it was illegal to print
Kurdish language materials.
It was a prohibited language and
government institutions and schools and
in public it was prohibited to speak it
even though not everyone followed that
rule in public.
That was the rule.
These days those policies have been
relaxed,
but Kurds still wants certain freedoms
like the right to use the Kurdish
language as the language of instruction
and regional schools.
There was a similar situation in Syria
and Iraq where the language was made
illegal and heavily suppressed.
From what I understand,
Iran has not aggressively suppressed the
Kurdish language,
but they have discouraged.
It's use and promoted assimilation to
the Persian language.
There was one country where Kurdish is
an official language and that is Iraq.
And there was one area where Kurds have
official autonomy and that's in Iraqi
Kurdistan,
which is run by the Kurdish regional
government.
They are Kurdish is the language of
instruction in schools and it's used in
the media since there are speakers of
both Karangi and Serani dialects in
Iraqi Kurdistan,
the government promotes both of them in
schools and in the media.
There was now also another defacto
autonomous Kurdish region,
and that is in Syria and Kurdistan.
It is known as Brittle Java due to the
civil war.
The Syrian government is no longer in
control of the area and all restrictions
on the Kurdish language are now
irrelevant.
Schools have introduced a new Kurdish
curriculum taught in Kurdish.
Okay.
The form of Kurdish used in Syria and
Kurdistan is Kurmanji with Kurdish
autonomy and Kurdish language schools
now existing in both Iraq and in Syria,
the curtis language might become
stronger and more standardized in the
future.
So what exactly is Kurdish like?
Well,
that depends on what variety of Kurdish
you're talking about.
So let's take a look at both could
Umangi and after that we'll look at
sorta Annie.
Here are a few interesting features of
could Umangi could a bungee nouns are
all either masculine or feminine and
there are four.
Now in cases it is generally an Sov
language.
They'll certain sentences are Svo put
'em on.
Ge has something called Ergot.
Tivity could Mangi has prepositions and
post positions and it also has something
called circle positions.
Let's have a look at the nouns and their
cases first could Manji has four.
Now in cases nominative or bleak
construct and Vocativ the case endings
are different depending on the gender
and number of the knelt.
Here's an example with the word for men,
middle,
middle of the row,
v,
neuro,
Vicky,
Vin,
and the roof.
Name Neuro.
No.
Now here's an example of using the word
for Woman Jin.
Ginny,
just you know Janeka Ginny Shin,
she none.
Shinon Junin [inaudible],
no.
[inaudible].
You may have noticed that the plural
case endings are the same for both
genders because it could Umangi gender
applies only to singular nouns,
not to plural nouns.
Okay,
let's look at some examples,
sentences and could Umangi here we'll
see.
That could Umangi is generally sov.
This means I see the men,
middle one dabine him.
So if we translate this sentence
directly,
it's like Aye man.
C as equals I,
middle of equals man and is the oblique
case marker.
And also the plural marker and to be
name is c so you can see that the
sentences Sov with the object coming in.
The middle positions I'm quoted in,
this means we are Kurdish or we are
Kurds.
If we tried to translate this sentence
directly,
it's like we Kurds are m equals,
we couldn't equals curd in equals r.
That's the present tense Copula.
Again,
we can see that this is Sov.
The sentence doesn't actually have an
object,
but it has something called a compliment
which comes in the same position as the
object.
Now why does the Noun in the first
sentence happen?
Ending on it marked in yellow,
but in the second sentence there isn't
one and that's because nominative case
has no ending in either singular or
plural and good manji.
So we only know it's plural from the
context and hear the context is that the
subject is we,
so we know what's plural.
Could Umangi exhibit something called
Ergot?
Tivity in ergots of languages,
the subject of a verb sometimes
functions as though it's the object of a
sentence.
It could Umangi.
This happens when the verb is in one of
the past tenses.
The agent that is the doer of the action
is in the oblique case,
like an object and the patient that is
the receiver of the action is in the
nominative case,
like a subject.
The verb then takes an ending to agree
with the patient.
Men,
oh deet.
We would translate this as I saw him,
but it's more like by me.
He was seen literally word for word.
It's me.
He saw,
but the verb ending confirms that he is
actually the receiver of the action.
We as dictum,
this means he saw me or by him I was
seeing word by word.
It's him.
I saw,
but again,
the verb ending confirms that I as the
receiver of the action.
So here him as the ending for the first
person singular and that matches the
patient of the sentence.
And that's I,
in this case,
I find ergotism it quite difficult to
wrap my head around.
It's not founded most Indo European
languages.
It's found in Kurdish,
it's found in Pashto and it's founded
some of the northern Indian languages.
Okay.
If we want to make that last sentence
negative,
we simply add a negative prefix to the
verb.
We as Ned Itam,
this means he didn't see me.
This is an example of how it could
Umangi uses lots of different affixes
could Umangi has prepositions which come
before noun phrases or pronouns and post
positions which come after noun phrases
or pronouns.
But it also has circle positions which
wraparound the noun or pronoun or the
entire Noun phrase.
For example,
the bed.
This means in front of the bed,
Marlo Darek care.
This means there's a tree in front of
our house.
So if we try to read the sentence word
by word,
it's in front house,
hour of tree,
there is now,
I don't know if have is the part that I
should have separated,
but the point there is that in front of
is split into two pieces and surrounds
the noun phrase.
Now let's look at some of those.
Could Umangi sentences again and we'll
compare them to some sorta nice
sentences.
Again,
here are the sentences for ic,
the men in Guzman,
g as literal one dabine him in.
So Danny.
Now one difference that you can see is
that the preposition is different in the
two different languages.
So in could Umangi it's as that means I
but in [inaudible] it's mean,
why does it mean?
Well in [inaudible] men is the first
person singular pronoun in the Oblique
case,
like an object Pronoun while as is the
nominative case.
But in sort I need the pronouns have no
cases.
So there's just one word and that word
has been another different word here is
pll con,
which is the word for man in I need,
that's different from the could Manji
word Middot van.
I think this is just an alternate word
for man in [inaudible] I think.
And so I need the word middle of means
man.
More as inhuman.
Now both words for men here have the
ending on,
but it's actually different in both
languages.
In could Manji it's the oblique case,
plural marker.
But and so the need,
there are no cases so and so donny,
it's just the general plural marker.
Now the sentences for we are Kurds in
could Umangi quoted then and in.
So Danny,
now here again,
we can see that the pronoun is different
in the two languages.
It's the first person plural pronoun.
But in putting on,
gee,
it's m and then saw danny,
it's Emma.
And in both languages we have the
present tense Copula in.
The only difference here is the
orthography and could on,
gee,
there's a space before the coffee love.
Now the sentences for,
I saw him in good Umangi men.
Oh deet and in Solani mean own Dick,
these sentences look quite similar.
The sorani sentence has an extra m
attached to the object of the sentence
that m is actually an ethics
representing the subject in a soda.
Any pass 10 sentence.
The subject is represented as an ethics
before the verb.
Here the subject is also stated overtly
as men,
but the sentence is possible without
that first word in court.
Manji it's not like that.
Now the sentences for he saw me in could
Umangi we as dictum and in so Danny Oh
money.
This example is similar to the last one.
We can see that the pronouns are
different and Sony,
because Sony has no case distinction and
we can see that and put them on g.
The verb has an ending that the Sadhana
verb doesn't have in the chronology
sentence and objects.
Suffix is attached to the end of the
verb.
And so Dani,
on the other hand,
a subject affix is added before the verb
and here are the sentences for he didn't
see me in [inaudible].
We as [inaudible] and in Daneen.
Oh [inaudible].
Now this sentence is basically the same
as the last one except that it's
negative.
And we can see that put them on g and
Sorta knee using negation in the same
way she wrote the sentences for,
there's a tree in front of our house in
could Umangi the bed,
Marlo Medda Dora care and in saw
[inaudible] that it kid Lebron
Guatemala.
Come on in the quarter Manji sentence.
We have a circle position that wraps
around the noun phrase,
but in the sorta and he's sentenced,
there is a preposition that comes before
the noun phrase and the preposition
that's totally different.
And the noun phrase itself is also
somewhat different.
My love means house and could Umangi
while model means house and sorta need
and may means hour increment g one.
And so donny,
yet mun the egg after mal is an
indefinite article which doesn't exist
in [inaudible] and the [inaudible] is a
connector which also isn't used in
liquid laundry sentence.
So as you can see there are some
significant differences between couldn't
Manji and sorta knee.
So which variety of Curtis should you
learn?
Well if you're planning on spending some
time in the Kurdistan region than it
would make sense to learn the variety of
the place where you planned to spend the
most time and in the future you could
always learn to adapt and speak a
different dialect.
By extension is Kurdish at difficult
language to learn?
Well,
there are some things like urgh activity
that are probably challenging for people
who have never encountered them before,
but probably some of the most
challenging things will be the dialectal
variation in the language and the lack
of a single standard language as well as
a general lack of learning materials.
On the other hand,
from what I understand,
if you have a previous knowledge of
Persian that will help you a great deal
in learning Kurdish and critics,
people are also all very welcoming and
friendly and very enthusiastic about
helping you to learn their language and
that kind of support is always very
encouraging.
Okay.
The question of the day for Curtis
speakers,
how easy is it for you to communicate
with speakers of other varieties of
Kurdish?
And do you consider them all dialects of
a single language,
or do you consider them distinct
languages?
And for people who've studied Kurdish,
what did you find challenging about the
language and in general,
what was your experience with the
language?
We'd like to hear about it in the
comments down below.
Definitely be sure to checkout lane,
focus on twitter,
on facebook,
and on instagram.
And again,
I'd like to say thanks to all of my
patrion supporters for continuing to
make Lang focus possible.
Thank you for watching and have a nice,
hey.